jasmine rice we've been eating oatmeal
but no bread today's Friday
day 11 social isolation social
distancing and it's been going good but
I really want to eat bread today I'm
gonna try to make bread today I've been
watching this youtube channel called
mocha this guy who is down in like south
south south Japan and he makes videos
about his life and bread making it looks
so good we've been eating rice we've
been eating jasmine rice we've been
eating oatmeal but no bread miss food
but I don't want to go out tapering so
[Music]
it's night time hmm I'm drawing on my
protein shake with his finish to work
out I'm hungry
the bread is just about to go into the
oven and it's looking really good this
is woody look like they're all different
kinds of shapes but that's because it's
my first time so if this is successful
it's basically like my first time
successfully breaking bread which is
great because this is basically like a
no-no kneading necessary kind of recipe
just good cuz that's the part where I
usually fail it's Scott plant is not
doing so well so we're trying to repot
it I'm just cleaning off the roots huh
but
swapping this out
Scot is propagating these populist
plants into our handy dandy little
propagation thingies that we got and
this is how we've been increasing the
number of pathos plans in our house this
is one of the plants that we propagated
and it's gotten very long it's actually
a little under water so I'll just give
it some water but it's a very healthy
plant this is the original pothos plant
that we take all these cuttings from
it's a very healthy very pretty plant we
got it from my parents my parents house
when they moved away from San Diego and
they moved to Japan so we went to their
house and took all of these plans
including that one to Scott how do you
propagate these plants put in water how
are you cutting them see these things
kamek as the root that's where it comes
out put that day and water and it'll
grow so easy huh so easy even I can
garden I don't think you're terrible at
gardening I'm pretty bad at I think
you're pretty good at propagating some
pothos yeah
[Music]
[Music]
happy weekend everybody I'm gonna make
some hamburger buns cuz we're gonna have
some burgers tonight's breakout over a
little quarantine sad frozen food it
actually hasn't been sad we've been
eating well but we've just been wanting
some beef so I'm gonna make some
homemade hamburger buns and I've never
made them before and I'm gonna try using
this recipe from food witches which is a
channel that Scott and I have watched
for ever chef Jon has taught us how to
cook basically so I'm gonna follow his
recipe for making these bones and hope
that it turns out okay yay baking on
Saturdays
[Music]
I interrupt our baking with an important
message banana bread with whipped cream
on top it's so good
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yeah they're know pretty good
[Music]
happy Sunday morning Sunday morning
raining fun this morning I thought that
we would make a Japanese breakfast
because it's been a while since we did
that and why not make the weekends a
little special yeah so I'm making some
salmon right here about this from the
Japanese market it's salmon kidding me
like this kind of cut and then won't be
salted and I just put it in the toaster
oven for a little bit because we don't
have a fish thingy I have a couple of
like pickles things that I'm gonna cut
up but I'm about to make the miso soup
and I thought maybe I would show you how
I do that because miso soup is actually
incredibly easy if you have the
ingredients and maybe you wanna know oh
so I've got about 3 cups of water in
this pot here that's more than enough
for two people so I start off with this
castle dashi which is basically just
like bonito fish soup base so think of
it like chicken stock they sell this at
all the Asian stores sometimes that like
Safeway and other supermarkets too I'm
just gonna add it in I usually just do
that much ish I'm gonna put some
shiitake in it today so I don't need
that much of the soup base and then I
just turn on the heat so this is boiling
now so you can kind of turn it down and
then this is where you add your good or
whatever you want to add in the adds
like the ingredients the insects I have
some shiitake mushrooms so I'm just
gonna put those in today but you can put
like walk on man like seaweed or fried
tofu or tofu sometimes I put like
cabbage onions my dad puts tomatoes
sometimes we can really are whatever you
want but today I'm just making some
mushroom miso soup because I had some
mushrooms once that cooked which doesn't
take that long you just had some miso
it's time for me so I got this
handy-dandy net thing where I put about
that much miso in there's no science to
it I just add it in and then add either
more miso rod
water depending on what it needs now the
important thing here is to not let the
miso boil after you've solved it because
that's when it starts tasting bad I
think that's pretty good if anything
it's a little salty so I'm just gonna
add some more water but that's it that's
how you make miso soup it's like the
easiest thing in the world after that
[Music]
Scott do you like Japanese breakfast
mm-hmm what's your favorite thing out of
all of these pickle stuff nickle stuff
yeah you eat hell a pickled stuff when
it's out
I put less there so that you wouldn't
eat it all we don't get whatever you
want later
[Music]
[Music]